tonight will be their final opportunity
to express their thoughts one character
had the exact same simple first and
final line in the hunger games saga is
that real
the journey many of the characters of
the hunger games went through was
intense and we saw them grow as fighters
and people their first and final lines
may have been simple in some cases but
they all hold their special meaning and
message in the films okay
it's okay
katniss's first line in the films is
appropriately to prim and she
demonstrated just how good of a sister
she is it's evident her younger sister
is one of the priorities in her life
it's a little tedious after all these
years but
there are much worse games to play
at the end of the saga we see katniss
come full circle as her nurturing side
comes out once more even despite
everything she's been through it feels
like an appropriate closing to the films
a simple moment between mother and
daughter
have you ever met him
haymitch
peeta joins the story by addressing
katniss his journey began with her so
it's pretty special to see how the two
end up together after the epic journey
they faced
you love me
[Music]
fortunately their love for each other is
totally confirmed
congratulations hey mitch abernathy is
wild and boisterous from the very top
and they say no one ever wins the games
his final line comes and understandably
it's about the hunger games it's clear
his feelings about panam the capital and
the games are strong with his last words
in the movie
welcome
welcome welcome
happy hunger games
and
may the odds be ever in your favor
if we didn't notice her wild and exotic
fashion we'd definitely notice effie
trinket for her particular and confident
voice as she addresses the public
i miss my wigs
we see her in different lights over the
course of the movies and her final line
leaves us with a quiet and genuine
moment that allows us to really relate
with her character
it's a short line to haymitch but the
care she feels for katniss really comes
through
war
terrible war
when we first hear president snow's
voice it's beckoning through the air and
a message katniss and gail have heard
before explaining why they are so quick
to make fun of it before the address
even begins
by the end of the saga we understand
that katniss and president snow's
relationship with each other is complex
and in a kind of twisted way
snow isn't just an enemy
oh my dear miss everything
i thought we'd agreed
never to lie to each other
a certain kind of loyalty would exist
between them even if it's a bit
unconventional
what are you gonna do with that when you
kill it
gail is looking out for katniss from the
first moment we hear him speak it might
seem like a simple ask but in fact it
demonstrates how gail helps to ground
and focus katniss
our hearts break a bit when we hear his
final line in the saga
all i know
is i'm always supposed to take care of
your family
no i'm sorry i couldn't
the events they went through had a major
effect on gail and while he
understandably changed going through it
he always remained true to himself and
those he loved
it's made obvious with his regretful
comment to katniss continuing to believe
he's the one responsible for prim's
death
katniss finnick's first line is just a
name but it exudes his casual and suave
attitude
he comes full circle in the end with the
same name but in a very different
scenario the final line gives us pretty
much the complete opposite feeling of
what we were getting from the same line
the first time no that's okay
sweet roo steals our hearts when she
first speaks especially after we've seen
her process the world she is in silently
for so long
her innocent request for a song at the
end shows just how special she is and in
the larger picture is what motivates
katniss to continue on and work to
become the mockingjay
what an honor it is to meet you
meeting coin her character comes across
as strong and powerful the final line
she says is presented with the same
sense of confidence as the first
mockingjay
may your aim
be as true
as your
heart is
pure
she is in the position of power that
she's worked for even though we know
soon after katniss changes all of that
primrose's first line with katniss is
simple but we can tell just how much
love there is between the two sisters
her final line is tupita who
unfortunately she doesn't get to see the
best side of
but we see the best of her as she still
tries to comfort him even when she hears
peta speaking so poorly about katniss
if his hair didn't catch our attention
his charisma on the screen as a host
definitely did there's no question he's
at home on this stage he's definitely
much less comfortable during his final
line
are you calling for a ceasefire
this moment of shock might just be one
of the only times we ever see flickerman
looking vulnerable
may i as the follow-up to seneca crane
heavens bee immediately brings the charm
the moment he meets katniss and asks her
to dance
he does appear more in the film after
this scene
of course it was
but his last line is delivered to
president al mccoy as he stays by her
side
miss everdeen
colonel box district 13 had a security
we get a very straightforward
introduction from boggs during his first
appearance
his final line is a kind of reversal of
the first
do what you came to do instead of
katniss boggs is the one hurting until
he eventually passes away in katniss's
arms but not without giving her warning
proving to us just how good a person he
was this definitely leaves us with a
positive memory of him that was one of
the bravest things i've ever seen
with your sister
my name is sinner
cinna starts and ends his journey on
screen with katniss his care and
admiration for her has been there from
the very start
remember i'm still betting on you girl
on fire seeing how their relationship
developed is pretty special
in this moment we get a chance to admire
and recognize the memorable bond
you guys look amazing
joanna's strong personality comes
through right off the top as she moves
confidently through the world striking
up conversation right away
go on
don't you want to know to see you dance
her final line is solid proof of how
spunky and independent she was as a
character
i think it's our tradition
seneca's support for the hunger games
comes off strong from the very beginning
perfectly setting up the first film
it's all confidence at first but of
course we see a very different reality
when he meets his end
that's excellent
but his confidence is still strong in
his last line
until i up and left
cressida's first and final lines are
with none other than katniss everdeen a
simple greeting where her sass is
evident from before she even says hello
her last line may be a simple one but
the support she has for katniss is
powerful
kato's first line comes in the midst of
a ton of action quick on his feet and
resourceful
it's the only thing i know how to do
bring pride to my district
by his last words the care and pride he
has for his district is really what
comes through
hard as she might have tried mrs
everdeen never got to be as close with
katniss as she may have wanted but from
her first line to her daughter laid
something out for you too we know she
cares and has put effort in
don't catness
the ointment's working her final words
are appropriately shared with katniss
once more we get to see mrs everdeen
having the opportunity of actually
helping to take care of her little girl
her motherly love really comes through
there they are this year's tributes
charismatic as can be from the moment we
meet him temple smith and flickerman
bring an amazing energy together
for temple smith's final line he
continues his lighthearted and playful
dynamic of caesar
even though he's not so subtly
commenting on whose side he's on it's so
interesting taking a look at how each
character evolved over the course of the
films and what it was like for those who
weren't in all of the movies each
journey was unique and the actor's
ability to bring their characters to
life is a major reason we still love
this franchise